we proved this before which is not so
hard okay and then you look at this
monster okay
the way to get to this is to try and
interpret like try and sift out all the
notation and work out what does this
signify okay and the answer is well this
is um this is a recurrence relation okay
um this here
what you proved earlier okay it's a
recurrence relation that connects
the integral of n plus one
with the integral for m
okay so this is the n plus one case and
it's climbing down the ladder now when
you look at this what is this and how
does it differ from that and the answer
is look this is the same yeah since the
input one but instead of this here
you've got i1 so what this is is after
you take like a recurrence relation is
kind of like a ladder right um this is
the image i gave you before so this
means just climb down to the next step
and from this one i could climb down to
the next step and the next step and this
means what happens after you've climbed
down all the steps okay so this is the
last step down the bottom or well i know
it could be but it's a bit trivial as a
case
and what this signifies is what are all
the steps that you are taking down the
ladder okay
so to demonstrate that here's what i'm
gonna do
i know this it's a given so the next
step down is go to
m
right because it's just it's one less
than that one okay so here's what i'm
going to write um everywhere i see n
plus one
i should write n yeah okay and
everywhere i see n
it should be exactly right so here's
where i'm gonna go i'm gonna say that
should be an n
right so i've gone down one step which
means here i should have one over n
minus one
i have n minus one
what's over here um one over n minus one
and
to the power of n minus one
okay i should have put a multiplication
in there okay
now that's really good um this is what
i've done here okay
i need to keep on going but obviously i
can't go forever it's in i don't know
what it is anyway okay
i just have to go far to establish a
pattern just like in series and
sequences and then i can use that
pattern to get to the end okay
so i've got one i've got two generally i
need three donuts okay so my next step
is to work out the recurrence solution
for n minus one three steps is enough to
establish the pattern it's a bit boring
to write them out but uh that's what
we're looking for as markers to see do
you really understand how the pattern is
progressing so again take all the ends
knock them down by one this is gonna be
here
i n minus one
i n minus two
okay one over
n minus 2 n minus 1
to the power of
n minus 2
cool
so then
dot dot dot okay now what should be the
next term that you do
or i should say what should be the last
term okay now
you have to think about this right where
you're going to end will have an i1 in
it
right
you don't want the last one to be an i
naught okay partly because like i bought
yeah what's the point uh one minus one
over x
zero
it's one yeah that's right okay yeah
good oh you've got value so you know the
end point right so therefore
uh being that this is one more than this
right this one over here my final one my
the recurrence relation sorry dot dot
dot that i should be working out now
should have
two on the left hand side because if i
have one here then zero will be here is
that right so i'll do this for two
so that gives me one over
two
i two
equals now this will be one over one
i one minus okay what's this thing in
here this will become one over two times
sorry
oh yeah one times two sorry you're right
one times two times
two to the power of
one
is that all right
and now you can kind of see why it's not
just arbitrary it has to end at one
because if it ended at zero you'd have
zero there okay
so this is the bottom rung i've gotten
there okay um i have all of the steps of
the ladder now laid out in front of me
and this is what i have to prove i have
to prove to get from the end plus one
from wrong all the way down to the
bottom realm this is what you have to do
okay so we have some space over here
i start off with my um
my beginning here
right
this is the whole particular okay
now i know that's equal to this okay but
i'm just gonna hold off on writing this
because i know what this is equal to
it's equal to the next one down right so
i'll pause from writing that for a
second i'll write the other bit because
that's i can evaluate that part so
that's going to be minus
1 over
n plus one two there
okay
plus this
but i know what this is it's this
so i can start to write this slide but
in just the same way that i did it
before i'm gonna skip writing this
because i know what it's equal to and
then write this part right because i
know what it's equal to minus 1 over
n minus 1 and 2 to the n minus 1.
so now i have to write this part but i
know what that's equal to okay so then
i'll have this
minus 1 over
uh n minus 2 and minus 1 2 to the n
minus 2.
and then where am i i need to write this
well they're all going to be the same
where i'm going to end is here
so i minus this minus this minus this
minus dot dot the last thing i subtract
is that one
so i've i've finished off my pattern
here right
and then i have to add on i want because
i don't have an i1 down here so i
actually have to put it on he actually
does appear which is why he's right
there
okay
okay now you look at this and you think
okay
this i can work with
the only thing out of this whole thing
that's positive is i want
so you're right you're not the front and
then all of these are so i might as well
take a minus sign out of the whole thing
okay and again i have i want sigma
notation here so i should write it in a
more helpful order maybe an ascending
order so i should start here i'm going
to reverse everything so i'll start with
him
right and because i've taken out a
factor of minus one these will now be
all added
and now i'm going to go in reverse so
this should be 2 by 3 by 2 square
and then i just need the third one to
establish the pattern so this would be
three by four by two cubed
and where am i going to end i'll go all
the way here
close bracket
okay
so
that they're reversing the order and
taking out the negative side now i think
i've made it sufficiently clear that
that fits segmentation so i can now say
i'm one minus okay and i can just pull
this guy out and pull him out
so i go
the sum of
one to m of
r r plus one to the r
right
so that's good that's manageable
that's
recognizing that it's a recurrence
relation and what they're asking us to
prove
is
now get rid of all the recurrence
relations or at least get rid of all the
ones you can until you get to the bottom
okay the as we will work out in a second
i1
you place that with one we can calculate
that that's a that's an integral we can
actually
evaluate